start small if you want to have success
as an entrepreneur then start small
don't go out make huge investments and
put tons of dollars into your company
use your time use your energy go out and
talk to customers get some money coming
into your business prove to yourself
that you can make this work and then
invest in the growth otherwise you're
probably gonna fail like most
entrepreneurs hi I'm Evan Carmichael
I believe that hungry entrepreneurs
deserve help and today Mason a question
from one of my readers avro you're
willing to say I've been struggling for
many years to start a simple business
I'm so scared I'm passional catering and
all forms when I'm afraid of failure
because I don't have money to waste what
stops me is I'm good at what I do and my
friends and family have said so but I'm
hard on myself and I don't know how to
stop putting myself down please give me
some advice if you can't ever listen
you're starting a service-based business
this is one of the best businesses to
start when you're first launching the
company the reason is your costs are low
I don't want you going out and investing
a lot of money into this company okay
don't go up buy equipment don't go out
and buy a new truck or van don't go out
and open up a shop don't spend money go
out and try to make money anything
you're gonna spend on if you have to buy
ingredients for your cooking it's all
based around customers don't spend money
until you're getting paid that's how you
prevent yourself from losing money
you're afraid of losing money that's the
answer
prove to yourself that you can do this
if you love catering then do it go for
catering you have to build a business
around your passion you can have success
but don't go out and start spending a
bunch of money that you don't have it
starts by going out landing the
customers one by one and fueling their
cash back into your business so you can
grow after you've shown to yourself that
you can make this happen if you're hard
on yourself that's great it's good to be
hard on yourself it'll mean that you'll
do a good job it means that you care it
means that when you put something out
it's gonna be quality people are gonna
love it and when that happens they're
gonna tell their friends and they're
gonna order from you again you're gonna
get repeat business and we're
furro customers and that's a great way
to build any kind of business but a
specialist service based business so
you're on the track you can't be so hard
on yourself though that you don't get
started you can't be so hard that you
think I'm never gonna make it
that's a limiting personal belief that's
going to hold you back if you love what
you do people say you're great at what
you do you owe it to yourself to try and
I'm not saying quit your job I'm not
saying go out and do this full-time I'm
not saying go out and buy a whole bunch
of equipment to get this thing going you
have to try you owe it to yourself to
try but start small you have a service
based business all your costs are
variable go out and find the customer
find someone who's willing to pay you
for what you do and make a profit off
your first sale it doesn't have to be a
huge deal you don't have to have your
whole vision planned out from the start
it'll come your customers will guide you
to your path on success get one customer
do an awesome job for them over deliver
like crazy make them over the moon happy
with the service that you provide and
the quality of your product and then go
out and find another one put the money
in make from them back into your
business keep expanding I don't want you
spending money in this business but I
don't want you holding yourself back
either because you're too afraid take
your shot
it's time good luck for those of you
watching if you like the video please
give it a thumbs up below and I want to
hear what you have to think about this
video please leave a comment section
below it always makes you want to do
more for you I really read all the
comments that come in every morning and
if you have a question for your own
business please leave in the comments
below thank you guys I'll see you soon